GABE WEISS: With almost
500 sessions at Next 2019,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see Worried
about application performance?
Cache it!
Then stay tuned, because
here's the Rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When developing an
application, there
are several things
that are fundamental--
speed, response time,
availability, and cost to run.
It doesn't matter how
good your application is.
If it stutters or takes
too long to respond,
it'll never succeed.
In-memory caching
is a common pattern
you see to achieve that
performance that you need.
In-memory caching helps
reduce latency and cost
by taking frequently
accessed data
and retrieving it from
memory, when possible, rather
than disk.
There's quite a bit going
on beneath the surface
to properly do caching.
So this means that while
it's a common concept,
there's plenty to learn about
optimization and your options,
particularly around
using a Redis process.
Redis is an open source
in-memory data structure store.
That means it holds anything
you put into it in active memory
instead of on disk.
Redis is popular because it's
more than just a key value
store.
It supports a bunch of
different data structures.
It has high availability
and persistence.
Redis is usable for many
different use cases,
not just for caching.
When you're moving to
the cloud, getting rid
of infrastructure management
is often top of the mind.
And that includes managing
and monitoring your cache.
So that's where Google's
Cloud Memorystore comes in.
Memorystore's a
managed solution,
fully compatible with
the Redis protocol,
which means you get all
the awesome of Redis
without any of the management.
Memorystore helps you
optimize in three main ways
since it's a managed service.
One, updates and security
patching are all taken care of.
Two, it's got high
availability and reliability
with automatic failover
and replication.
And three, it's scalable
and it's secure.
Cloud Memorystore comes
in two different packages
to suit your needs.
First, the basic tier-- it's
a standalone regional instance
of Redis.
And then the standard tier is a
cross-zone replicated instance.
Since the GA launch six
months ago, many updates
have been added to Memorystore,
including manual failover
for testing, access from
App Engine second generation
runtimes, more regions,
metrics, and some compliance
certifications.
But these expansions
don't stop there.
The team's currently working
to add many more capabilities
to Memorystore--
things like shared VPC
and instance-level
authentication and Redis
clustering.
In addition to a
live demo showing
how simple it is
to set all this up,
the talk goes over
some best practices
for storing data, eviction
policies, and memory
management, and then
a breakdown of what
to monitor from
Stackdriver-- things
like CPU usage and alerts, keys
present in memory, failovers,
and how to best scale
based on growth.
If you'd like to
see the full talk,
check out the link in
the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Cloud YouTube
channel for more great
Next Rewind content.
Thanks for watching.